Okay.
Welcome back to Garys Economics.
Today, we are going to do something different
and we're going to have a guest on the channel,
an economist for the very first time.
One of my favorite economists working today.
I very often get asked on this channel,
where else can we go to learn about economics?
What other stuff can we read?
How can we learn more?
And there are a lot of
economists who I like working today.
There's obviously a couple of
French guys working on inequality-
Piketty and Zucman.
But the person who I always recommend, because I
think he is the best at writing about economics
in a way that is accessible and relatable for
ordinary people is today's guest on the channel.
So I'd like to welcome Ha-Joon Chang.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for coming.
I think I'll just introduce briefly
how we met and how I got to know you.
So, I quit banking in 2014, and when I came back, I
was sort of looking about how can I change the economy.
And I didn't really know much about the work getting
done in economics today, and I got invited to a small,
what can I say, lecture series that you were doing?
Yeah.
When was it?
Was it 2015, perhaps?
'15, '16, I forget.
2015,
I was invited to a lecture series which you
gave to a smaller audience, and I was lucky to
watch a few lectures you gave about
how, I think it was How Poor Countries Become Rich.
And I was very impressed at the time about
basically how you seemed to have thought the
problems through and delivered answers rather than
kind of relying on rigidly mathematical models.
That's kind of you.
And I was very impressed at basically how
you were just able to communicate ideas in
a way that ordinary people would understand.
So, was very impressed, and I'm very happy
to have you as the first guest on the channel.
Thanks.
Yeah, actually those lectures have
been made into this lecture series called
Economics For People and available on INET
website, The Institute for New Economic Thinking.
Yes.
I sometimes get people tweet photos of me
asking you a question, saying, "Oh, here's-"
That's right, you asked some sharp questions.
Yeah.
Looking, looking younger and fresher,
less jaded by politics.
Yeah, yeah.
So would you be able to introduce yourself a
little to the audience, talk a little bit about
why you chose to study economics, when you started, why
you chose to move to the UK to study,
because I know this is not where you're from
originally.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm Ha-Joon Chang.
I'm a professor at SOAS,
University of London, at the moment.
I used to teach in Cambridge for over three decades.
I've moved to SOAS recently.
Yes, I was born in South Korea in 1963.
That was right at the beginning of
the country's so-called economic miracle.
And, you know, really that was where
I grew up and when I grew up that I wanted to study
economics, because, you know, at the time, South Korea
was growing at like 10%, 12%, sometimes at 15.
This is when you were sort of in your teens?
That's... Yeah, that's right,
In the
'60s and '70s, yeah.
And yeah, I mean, the, people's living standards
were rising really rapidly and, you know, the new
buildings going new towns are forming.
Yeah, so there were a lot of good things
going on then because, you know, at that, level
of income, you know, the South Korea's income,
per, per capita income, you know, for example, in
the, the ni- early 1970s when I was a primary
school student was like, $400, yeah?
Yeah, so I think...
It was a very poor country-
Yeah.
... which meant that this economic growth
really, was literally
a matter of life and death, you know.
Yeah.
Because that, in that, at that
level of development, if your economy grows at
5% rather than the 1%, it means that,
you eat one more bowl of rice
Was it still like a very agricultural economy-
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
at that time.
but you know, like 60... 50-60% of
people were in the countryside, engaged in farming.
But, also because the
country was industrialising rapidly
literally millions of people were arriving
in Seoul, the capital city, and Busan,
Ulsan, these industrial cities in the
Southeast to find jobs in factories, yeah?
But the life was very hard for the workers,
you know, because, this was a time when
these workers are working 13, 14 hours a day,
six and a half days a week.
In factories, in cities?
Ye- yeah.
Exactly, yeah.
And some factories refused to
serve soup in the canteen so that they don't
have to give extra toilet break,
No, no.
this was a very, very harsh time.
Yeah.
But, you know, things
were improving.
On the other hand, you know, you had
these workers you know, being
worked to death, and, you know, slums
springing up in urban areas, and then the-
Okay.
... property developers mobilising
these thugs to beat people up,
to clear illegal settlements.
So you've got this rapidly urbanising and, like, growth
is high, incomes are growing, but living standards
are still really poor for a lot of people,
That's right.
the cities are growing in sort of slum fashion.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And then there were a lot of tension because,
you know, the country was between 1961 and
'87 ruled by a military dictatorship.
Even though this military government,
was able to engineer this rapid
economic development into the very brutal-
yeah.
And as I grew up, I just, I wanted to
understand what's going on around me.
And you, you're, you were growing
up in, like, a middle-class family?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In Seoul?
That's right, yeah.
My father was a high ranking civil servant,
in the Ministry of Finance, and yeah.
I mean, okay, I mean,
we were not rich, but, well off, yeah?
I guess by the standards of a career
which was quite poor at the time.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So, when I was a kid, our house was the
only house in the neighborhood with a TV, you know?
Okay.
So people went to... came to our
house to watch a football matches,
a boxing match.
So you were witnessing, I guess, it
sounds like a period of really rapid economic change
and economic growth, and, like,
that interested you and excited you.
That's right, yeah.
So there were a lot of positive things
happening, but, also a lot of negative things, yeah?
I mean, this
exploitation of workers, you know?
Yeah.
Political repression, you know?
It's interesting to hear you talk about the, like, the
rapidly growing cities and the rapidly growing slums
because obviously at the moment, we have
a government that is obsessed with growth,
and they want to build, they want
to build, they want to build.
And, I come from, like, a
very poor part of East London.
Yeah.
And I'm seeing, you know, I'm sure it's not the
same, but I'm seeing this, like, rapid growth
of these poorer outer London suburbs,
and basically turning into slums.
Yeah.
I was saying before, the Daily
Mail went to my house last week.
And I think they wanted to do, like, the
house I grew up in, and they wanted to do a story
like, "Oh, you know, Gary said he was poor, but he's
actually not." And the story they actually wrote
was, "Oh my God, this place is a slum." They
couldn't believe it. so it's interesting to see
You know, And I often worry that this like,
this rapid, like, move for growth
will lead to the slumification of London.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I mean, of course, I mean,
it was worse in Korea at the time because
the general living standard was lower.
But yeah, I mean, if you, expand too fast
these builders are not going to build
houses of good standard.
Yeah, and of course, we're only a few years
out from the Grenfell disaster, you know?
Exactly.
I sometimes worry that this, "Let's slash the
red tape," sometimes feels shocking to me.
Yeah.
I mean, the housing problem has to be
solved by, you know, the regulation and the
more equal distribution of assets, I mean, you
cannot solve it by building more houses.
It seems a bit naive to me.
But let's get back to, you're a child in Korea.
It was my fault. You're interested
in economics, and you decide that you,
you moved to, in the UK when you were 18?
No, no, no, no.
Actually, I went to university in Korea.
Okay.
In Seoul?
Yeah.
So we studied economics, and,
yeah, some professors were different,
but most of the professors were just
teaching this equilibrium models, you know?
The similar models to what I would have learned.
Exactly.
Mathematically less sophisticated,
but the same idea.
Yeah.
Okay.
So just these are like basically
very mathematically, mathematically complex,
mathematical equilibrium models, not so much
stuff on the history of economic thought, perhaps?
Yeah.
We had a course in the history of economic thought.
And you don't mind me asking,
what years would
you have been studying in Korea?
Yeah.
So I entered university in 1982.
Okay.
And graduated in 1986, and came to England in
the summer of '86 to start my master's.
Okay, just before was born.
Exactly, yeah, yeah.
I'm old, yeah.
So well, I, yeah, entered the university,
most of the professors were, you know,
teaching this abstract...
In Seoul?
Yeah, Seoul National University.
And many of my friends couldn't take it
seriously, you know, because, there's this huge
upheaval going on outside the classrooms, you know?
Economic development, export success,
political repression, you know?
Yeah.
In 1980, the second military government
committed this massacre in
actually my father's hometown killing
thousands of people who are protesting against
the coup d'etat and, you know?
So, a lot of us got interested in
finding out whether there's
another way of thinking about economics.
So you went into university.
And you got very interested in economics, and
you were kind of almost amused by
your university basically doing maths.
That's right.
And there's not much discussion of, there's
all of this crazy stuff happening, you know?
Exactly.
This is, you know, one of the great
modern economic miracles, right?
at this period of Korean economic growth.
Yeah.
So you kind, you kind of thought...
I mean, I had a similar thing, really.
Like you sort of, you, I think sometimes
people are really amazed when I tell them,
we don't talk about the housing crisis.
That's right, yeah.
And we don't, we don't talk
about the cost of living crisis.
Uh-uh.
What we do is maths.
Yeah.
And I did my undergrad in the mid-2000s.
And I did my post-grad 2017 to '19.
Yeah, and while you were
doing this, there's
one of the biggest financial
crises in the history of capitalism.
Yeah.
And many professors-
I'm kind of surprised to hear
that even, you know, this is 30 years earlier
in Korea.
You were also doing this very, very
heavily mathematised form of study.
That's right, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so I just wanted to study something
different, and I found out that there were a
few universities in England and the United States
where you could study non-Neoclassical economics,
Marxist economics, development economics,
So, just to make clear,
we're talking, you didn't want to do just this
kind of very specific heavily mathematised.
That's what you mean when you say Neoclassical?
Yeah, yeah, I mean already Neoclassical
economics was very heavily mathematised.
So Neoclassical is basically like the...
at the moment at elite universities there's
kind of one... there's basically there's one-
Exactly, yeah.
one kind of economics that you're taught
almost, from my perspective, almost as if
it's like physics, like a physical science.
That's right, yeah.
So this is a particular approach to economics
which assumes that the world is made up of
this selfish rational individuals, and they,
you know, try to get ahead and compete with
each other, and that's what generates wealth and-
And in particular, what I often
talk about on this channel
is that these models, these kind of
large-scale heavily mathematical models,
they tend to use what they call representative agency.
Which means that rather than talking about, we have
whatever 60 million people in the UK or 40 million
people in Korea, you just look at the average.
You say let's look at one guy, the
average guy, the representative guy.
Which of course means
there is no inequality.
Exactly, by definition,
There's no equality in distribution.
And you were studying the... that was the
same thing you would have been studying.
Yeah, exactly, and yeah, still
laughing when I, remember that incident
you know, these models that really
came on stream in a major way in the 1980s,
because yeah, before it was more of
a general equilibrium and that, that kind of stuff
and, yeah, it, in my early days in Cambridge,
someone was, giving a... a seminar
using this representative agent model.
Yeah.
He also added this assumption that
this agent is non-infinitely lived.
Okay, well, I'm glad to hear it.
We are like looking at this guy and
one of us asked, "What does that mean,
'non-infinitely lived'?" And another guy said,
"Well, I guess it means that we all die in the end."
Yeah.
You know what mean?
There's no sense of realism there.
I mean, just whatever makes it
mathematically neat.
Yeah.
I wondered, so-
You say
moved to Cambridge in '86?
Exactly, yeah.
To do your post grad, masters?
That's right, masters and PhD, and then I
studied with Professor Bob
Rowthorn who was a famous Marxist economist.
Okay.
Yeah, although, I mean, he
did lots of other things and,
he didn't insist that, I follow his approach, so my
approach is a bit different, from him, but
I really thank him for, kind of showing me different
types of economics and, you know, teaching
me how to kind of reconcile them if I have to and...
So you chose to go to Cambridge because you
thought that Cambridge was teaching
like a more like diverse range of-
That's right,
ways of looking at economics?
Yeah, that, at that time Cambridge was of
course at the bastion of Keynesian economics.
Okay.
Can you just quickly describe what
that means to our viewers who might not know.
Yeah, Keynesian economics is economics
that was kind of invented by the early
20th century British economist John
Maynard Keynes, who... well like you, made
a lot of money in the financial market.
He's one of a few economists who actually
makes money in the financial market
because surprisingly many economists that
when they invest in financial market
they fail.
Not so surprising to me.
But he was rooted in, so I think
one of the best economists of all time.
Yeah, exactly.
And he lived through The Great Depression.
That's right, yeah.
So his argument was look, you cannot treat
the economy as a household, yeah?
Yeah.
That is the mistake that the
current Labour Government is making, yeah?
We've maxed out
our credit card, you know, we cannot spend more.
Of course you can, but
the point is that...
He's basically saying, if you tax people,
like tax working people more and you don't... the
government stops spending, you'll basically cause
this kind of economic depression which is that
there's not enough spending, businesses will fail.
Then more people will lose their jobs.
And, well yeah, this is-
Yeah, so his point was you know,
that your income is my spending, you know.
My spending is your income, yeah.
Although we're kind of in this weird situation
in the UK now where we have a government that
seems to want to spend but is kind of not able
to spend and we'll discuss more on this.
But, so basically I think the point
you're making is at universities, especially
elite universities, economics is kind of taught
like there's this one way of doing things.
Exactly.
Which you're calling Neoclassical,
neoliberal, which is this very highly
mathematised, rational individuals, we look
at the averages, but there are other ways of
thinking about things like Keynesianism, Marxist
economics.
And you wanted to, I guess, study a wider
variety so that's why you went to Cambridge.
Absolutely, yeah.
Cambridge was, you know, Neoclassical
economics was not so dominant until the
1950s and '60s, but from the '70s it started
really pushing out other schools because they
are more kind of, accepting of the status quo.
They don't
ask awkward questions, yeah?
So it was that really becoming
dominant, but there was still in the '80s
a few places here and there where
Neoclassical economics was not dominant.
Cambridge was one of those places.
Is Cambridge still like that now?
No.
Okay.
Because when I... so I went to London
School of Economics, 2005 to 2008, and
really to be honest, I was not, I was not
even really aware that there were other ways-
Exactly, yeah.
No, no, that's how it is, these days and, you know.
Yeah.
So I deliberately
wanted to come to Cambridge.
Luckily I got accepted, but you know, when
I told people that I want to study in
England, I mean, a lot of people in Korea-
Your friends and-
just couldn't understand it because
you know, we had no historic
relationship with England, so studying
abroad meant 90% going to the US and
maybe 5% to Germany, 5% to France.
Hardly anyone came to England,
And yeah, I mean, moreover people
thought wanting to study anything other
than Neoclassical was career suicide, yeah?
I mean, career hadn't even begun, but you know.
Yeah.
So.
So have you got any advice
to... We sometimes get messages
from young people who are studying economics
or are interested in studying economics.
Sometimes we even get messages from people
who are really interested in the ideas that we
talk about on this channel, we talk a lot about
inequality, and they say, "Where can I
learn about these things, where should I study?
is it gonna be a problem if, for me, for like
career advancement?" What advice would you give to
young people who are interested in studying
economics and actually learning about the economy?
Yeah, I mean, it's getting more and more
difficult to study economics in a kind of pluralistic
way that accepts different theoretical approaches
and try to learn the best from all of them,
because most universities will
teach you a very, very narrow curriculum
completely
dominated by mathematics, yeah?
Yeah.
So basically a lot of people
want to study economics because they want to
understand inequality, you know, cost of living crisis,
financial crisis and then they go to
the university and they don't learn any of
those, and then they do maths for three years
and they graduate, you know?
Maybe you could speak a little bit,
because you were teaching at Cambridge
for quite a long time, right?
As you've been teaching at SOAS so you've
been an economics professor and teacher
at universities for a number of years.
Yeah.
My experience of studying economics is when I did
my undergrad I was at LSE, it's a very elite university.
So lots of wealthy students.
The truth is for me, I found the
majority of students there on the undergrad,
to be honest,
I think they were not, and I include myself in this.
We were not really that interested in the economy,
really.
We were there because we thought, I think rightly to
some degree, that economics, especially at an elite
university like LSE, was a way to get a well-paid
job.
It is, yeah.
So how... What... Is that what you were
seeing when you were at Cambridge as well?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
But you know, I mean
there are different people, so the...
Yeah, even in Cambridge, I would
say, you know, 30% of the students were
quite interested in the real world problems.
And Cambridges-
It's funny that, it's quite a small minority
but that's the same, I think at LSE
was probably slightly less.
Yeah, to be fair, Cambridge
still offers a slightly more diverse
curriculum than LSE.
It used to be actually very
real world oriented and diverse
and so until about 2005, yeah?
And then does a major curricular reform
that made it very mathematical and...
Yeah, so that another story, but, so...
But the problem is that even
for those 30%, 35%, I mean-
That's just the nature of the study, the ma- the
The ability to think about the economy is
beaten out of them, yeah?
I think, yeah, I think your
gestures are correct.
So for me, okay, so I well, when I did my
undergrad I was not interested in economics.
Really.
Other than its ability to get me a good job.
And that was almost everyone at LSE was like that.
But then I went back to do a master's,
at Oxford, '17 to '19, and what's
interesting about that is the master's is
not really like necessary to get a good job.
That's true.
If have a good undergrad.
So then that means that some of
the people who did the master's
a much bigger percentage of them
were kind of interested in
economics.
But of course they've all had this experience of,
you go to do your undergrad and maybe you go in quite
naively thinking, "I'm gonna learn about the economy."
But the actual experience is you have to do a lot
of very, very difficult, essentially algebra exams.
Algebra and calculus exams, and, you
know, it's just like complicated maths.
And then those exams are really hard.
So then you, you don't... Unless you're
like super smart, you don't really have-
Time to do anything else.
Yeah, you, you don't have time to step back and be
like, "Well, you know, does it make sense that we
don't look at the... have any wealth distribution
in the model?" You don't really ha- you know,
you need to be, and also if you were to think,
ask those questions, who do you ask them to?
You know, I was at Oxford.
Oxford had one guy who looked at inequality.
Was his name
Tony Atkinson?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And he died
1 year before I entered.
Yeah, so I applied with the hope...
He was a yeah, very influential
economist in the field of inequality study.
I think Piketty was quite an influence.
Yeah, yeah.
So by the time I got there, there was not
even anybody to speak to about inequality.
And then, and, you know, you have to,
you have to study really hard.
And, you know, I didn't really
care about my grades in master's
but, you know, it does whip it out of you,
because if you, if you, you have to
do so much maths and it's difficult.
Yeah.
And there's... and it kind of whips out
anyone who actually wants to ask these
big questions, it's like, well, everyone
else is doing 100 hours a week of maths.
And you're sitting around asking stupid questions.
That's right, yeah.
Yeah, so I think it does kind of whip,
and I thought it was really, really sad.
Like, I thought the smartest kids
on that Oxford post-grad course
they all dropped out of economics.
Because it was like, well, the guys were curious.
It was so clear there is no space here for people
who are curious about the economy.
Yeah.
This conversation reminds me of what the radical
Keynesian economist, Joan Robinson said.
I mean, Robinson was one of the few...
Was she at Cambridge?
... Yeah,
female economist, yeah, was a big
name in the Keynesian economics.
I mean, she should have got greater
recognition, but she was very left-wing
and asked a lot of awkward questions, and
yeah, therefore she was pushed back.
But she once famously said
that, "I had to learn to think because I
wasn't all that good at math," you know?
Yeah.
I think it, I think it, yeah.
Sometimes, maths becomes
substitution for thinking, yeah?
Yeah, well, I think, no, I think
that's a really good point.
I think that's a really good point.
The obsession, it's insane, Because you
know, especially for that Oxford post-grad.
You know, it's very difficult to get into,
Oxford's a very prestigious university.
These are really, really smart kids, and
the reality of it is we spent two years
locked in tiny windowless rooms inverting matrices.
That's right.
It's insane.
It really, really is insane, but I think this,
I want to make this point to our viewers.
because the point I often make is, you know,
at the end of the day, these are the guys
who are controlling the economy,
making the decisions about the economy and-
It's quite worrying, isn't it, yeah?
Well, the other point that I make is, and this
something I wanted to ask you about, was so when
I did my undergrad, I think LSE is probably the
worst for this, but I don't think it's unusual at all.
The vast majority of the students wanted to be traders.
Or at the very least to work in finance.
And the vast majority of the students with
the best grades did go on to become traders.
Does that mirror with what you've seen
as a professor watching students go through?
Yeah.
I mean, you cannot blame them,
you know, they've...
No, I did it myself.
That's right.
Going into trading, I mean, you will be
making five, ten times what you could be
making in any other uh, possible uh, profession
The civil service or whatever.
So that is natural, yeah?
But, you know, the trouble is when
you train people in this particular way, basically
maths, and then put them in charge of the economies,
a bit like
training people in, say, biochemistry
and then make them medical doctors, yeah?
Yeah, so it's related, yeah?
So you have to understand the
principles of biochemistry and so
in order to understand human body and so on,
but you need clinical experiences, yeah?
You should have actually looked
at actual patients
to know how to diagnose them as well.
Yes, this is, this is the,
the big thing that I feel is missing.
And to be honest, it's why I was impressed
when I went to your lecture series.
Which is, I think that from my personal
experience, first of all, these guys who study
economics to high level, they're smart guys.
They're very good-
Of course, yeah.
To be honest, they're very good at maths.
Yeah.
But I think there's really a lack of
being able to, or even in a sense thinking that it's
a thing you should do, step back and look at what
you're doing in a, in a sort of big picture sense.
Yeah.
I always remember when I was at Oxford, we had
one lecture, and there was a discussion
of like the aftermath to the 2008 crisis.
Which the recovery was much weaker than everybody
predicted, and they were saying, "We don't know
why." And I put my hand up and I asked this guy-
"Okay, well, why do you think it was?"
And he said, and I think this is
one of the funniest things I've ever heard.
He said, "We're not sure why, but we think it
was because of an exogenous shock to consumption
savings preferences." Which is, oh, this me,
I have to explain this to the audience, right?
Exogenous is a technical term in economics modeling
which means something outside of the model has changed.
So I've asked him, "Why do you think..." You
know, this is a real thing that happened in the
real world.
"Why do you think the recovery was so weak?" And he
said, without like a hint of irony, "We think something
outside the model changed." And that is crazy.
It's a cr- but I think it shows exactly when you
make a guy do so, do so much maths in the model
they forget that the model is not the real world.
And when you reach the point that you start
explaining things in the real world by using
technical terms, saying something outside
the model has changed, I think this captures
like exactly what has gone wrong.
And the maddest thing is, nobody
in the hall even laughs, you know?
They just think, they're just like, they...
I think this form of like very, very
intense forcing people to do maths
is almost like a brainwashing.
That's right, yeah, yeah.
No, I mean, first of all, you know, that
what this guy was implicitly saying was
"Suddenly people didn't want to spend."
Yeah, which is the whole answer, yeah.
Why, yeah?
Yeah.
Some I don't know, alien overlord that...
Yeah, came in and changed the world.
Yeah.
That's right, came and changed people.
I mean, that's so stupid.
But secondly, even if that is the case, then
why are you not putting that into your model, yeah?
Yeah, it's-
So it's that,
like, you know, I mean, unfortunately, this
is now kind of verging on
becoming a theology, you know.
I mean-
Yeah, yeah, I saw.
I don't know if you realise.
I know you're not on social media.
There is a clip of you kind
of going viral on social media.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
Are you aware of this?
Well, yeah, my son, who's...
who's working in the the Royal Institution.
He's a biologist.
But even he saw it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People keep sending it to me, yeah, of you
basically saying like... And I think it's a
really good point and I think it's totally true.
Like it or not, economics has become a bit like
Catholic theology in medieval Europe.
It has, basically become
the language of the rulers.
So, if you don't speak economics, you
cannot participate in any debate.
Unless you're able to speak in this language, use these
terms, you're basically not allowed to have an opinion.
And it kind of locks... To be
honest, like, it locks poor people
out of the conversation.
Yeah, absolutely.
This... I mean, this scary parallel
with Catholic theology in medieval Europe
Yeah.
So, theology at the time was justifying
whatever is going on in the world.
Yeah?
Yeah.
You know, famine and exploitation.
You know, the abuse of power.
Whatever, it's all in God's will, yeah?
Today, whatever is going wrong in
the world is justified by economics.
Yeah, must be-
This must be what is best for the economy.
Exactly, yeah.
Yeah.
Best of all possible worlds, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
And to make it worse-
they, they use that term a lot in economi-
well, they use, "The first best optimal."
Yeah, exactly.
Have you, have you read Candide by Voltaire?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so there's a book, it influenced
me a lot in my book, where he talks about-
this, It's by Voltaire.
Hundreds of years ago.
He says that back in the day
they justified everything by saying,
"If it wasn't supposed to be like this-"
That's right.
"... God wouldn't have made it like this."
Yeah, exactly.
"This must be the best of all possible worlds or
God would've made it differently."
Yeah.
And economics uses sometimes similar language.
They say like, "The first best optimal outcome."
"If it wasn't supposed to be like this,
the economy wouldn't have made this."
Absolutely.
But what I want to... The point which I
make a lot on this channel is if you reach
high levels in this debate about how we should
run the economy, how we should manage the
economy, so if you become a prestigious academic
or if you become a high level politician, or if
you become, working in the central bank, or
even high level media, you're quite rich by that point.
Yeah.
And then what you have is a group of rich people
basically refusing to allow poor people
into the conversation because they're
saying, "Sorry, you can't speak the maths,"
saying, "We think nothing should change"
as a way of justifying a system which, from where I'm
standing, appears to make the rich richer every year.
Yeah.
And is, is... It's crushing living standards.
Yeah, we have to remember, you know, during
the, the medieval times, the Vatican
did not allow the Bible to be translated
into vernacular languages.
It all had to be in Latin.
So most people couldn't read Latin.
And therefore, they had to just take
the priest's word for... I mean, the...
Yeah, the face value, yeah?
This is basically why the Daily
Mail has run four stories on me
in four consecutive days, because...
You are dangerous.
What I'm trying to do on this channel, and I think
it's also a lot of what you're trying to do,
in the work that you do, but also your books,
which are very accessible to ordinary people
is, you're trying to explain what's happening to
ordinary people in a language they can understand.
And well, I talk about it a lot on
this channel, what I think is happening
is that the distribution is changing.
The wealth distribution is changing in front of us.
Ordinary people are getting poorer.
The rich and the very rich are getting richer.
And I think if people... You know,
I said it a lot on this channel,
what I see my mission as is really quite simply
getting people to understand what is happening.
Absolutely, yeah.
Because if people understood what is happening and also
what's goIng to happen, so in my opinion, and don't
know how much of our videos you've watched, I think
this crisis of wealth inequality will get worse.
I think it's, it's really going to...
It's already decimated the working classes
in the West.
I think it's starting to decimate the middle class.
You're seeing how it's basically impoverishing
the government, and that is happening in a
context of rapidly growing wealth of the richest.
Yeah, and now, I mean, in places like the US,
although it's happening in other countries
at a lower level, you know, now
there's blatant money politics, yeah?
Yeah.
Well, I saw on the news this morning- we had
Elon Musk offering people a million dollars-
Exactly,
if you voted his way.
Yeah.
Well, this is another point I like to make
a lot, which is, distribution of wealth is
distribution of power and, it's control over
resources, but it's also control over the media
and it's also control over the politicians.
Exactly.
Now, we're in a downward spiral
because it's feeding into each other.
So, the more inequality, economic inequality
gives more power to this rich people
Yeah.
Which they can then use to take more power.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I talk about this a lot actually.
I talk about basically these dynamics
which you're talking about, which is
the more power they have, the more they can...
The quicker they can take the rest of the power-
which means they will then have more power.
And I think that this is the kind of
spiral that, that we are in, and
yeah, I'll be honest, I speak about it a lot.
I'm really worried about where this goes.
Like, on the first level in terms of living standards,
but also in terms of, in terms of politics, because...
Well, first, I suppose, I'll ask you this question.
I think, unfortunately, that unless we get some
change on taxation inequality, which I don't
think we will get, at least in the short term,
I think living standards in... for
the West, for the working class, for the
middle class, will continue to decrease.
Do you think that's likely?
You have so-called Labour Government
cutting benefits, yeah?
Yeah.
Disability benefits of all things, yeah.
I think unless... I know, you know, I'm trying
to get some influence with, with the Labour Party
obviously the government of this country. Why do you
think they're so reluctant to discuss taxing the riches?
Well, I mean, a a kind of
charitable interpretation is that
they are scared of the financial market, yeah.
Yeah, but you know...
Yeah, but I think-
If you borrow a lot, so I think at the moment
we're in this space where they, they want
to borrow, it's just borrow, borrow, borrow.
But if you borrow from the financial markets,
you know, you are essentially borrowing from the rich.
Yeah.
If borrowing is your only plan
then you are a slave to the financial markets.
You know, if I... if my plan is to borrow from you,
then I need you to agree to that.
If my plan is to tax you, I
don't need you to agree to that.
So I think really the way to break out
of that fear of financial markets is to start
talking about, about taxation and, and...
well, I'll tell you what I think.
You didn't ask, but I'll tell you what I think.
I think these guys, they're being
pressured by their rich funders.
I think they don't want to push back on it basically.
But I think also, I think there is a real lack of
economists in looking at things like the distribution.
Yeah, so unfortunately I think that
economists in the Labour Party, they
are still living in this mental cage
built by Margaret Thatcher, yeah?
Yeah.
So the high taxation for the rich is bad, you
know, the private ownership of everything is
good, that kind of... I mean, unfortunately,
I'm sure that they are uncomfortable with it, but
they haven't been able to develop
a counter-narrative, yeah?
No, let's look at some facts.
You know, in the 1960s and '70s, Britain was one
of the most equal countries in the world, you know?
People don't often realise it.
The country was growing faster than
what it is... has been growing
in the last 30 years,
despite having, you know, top
income tax rate of 80%, yeah?
Yeah.
In the US at the time, the top income
tax rate was even higher, 90%, yeah?
But it was growing much faster
than what it is doing today, you know?
At least try to use those historical
facts to develop some counter-narrative, you know?
But since they haven't developed this
counter-narrative and basically given up on
the taxing the rich taxing wealth and so on
what do they do?
There's only one
way to spend more which is
borrowing which that creates
the problem that you just talked about.
Yeah, I th- I think it's, I think it's kind of
the same thing which I said before, which is like
a bit of an inability, and I think maybe we kind
of teach this a little bit in the way that we...
the way that we educate people in university now. An
inability to step back and look at the big picture.
And the big thing which I often talk about
was, you know, and the reason I started
my channel was at the beginning of COVID,
it was very clear that the UK government and the
US government and basically all Western governments
were going to give a huge amount of money out.
And the UK deficit as I said is 1 trillion, and all
wanted to know, because my background is distribution
inequality, who is going to get that 1 trillion?
That's the only thing I wanted to know.
Because you know, the US number is, I
think, $13 trillion, you know, huge numbers,
you're obviously going to change the distribution
here, you're obviously going to change the distribution
but I think it was so amazing, just nobody asked.
Nobody, and I think we've... I think personally,
it goes back, I honestly think it goes back to
the way that we teach our economic students.
This way that we just whip them into do the maths,
do the maths, do the maths, don't question the model,
don't think about the big picture, and then you
reach a point where, you know, we can give out 1
trillion, the Americans can give out $13 trillion,
and because our models never question distribution,
nobody even asks where it's going to end up.
I think it's, I think it's amazing.
Well this extra money was basically
given to banks and other financial institutions,
which they refused to give it to productive
enterprises that need this money for investment,
to give to ordinary consumers...
sorry, ordinary citizens, yeah?
Yeah.
I mean, why couldn't they do it with
more kind of taxation
you know I mean?
Okay, I mean if you think generally high level
of taxation is not a good thing, at least
you can, have emergency taxations, yeah?
A lot of countries did that, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
During wartime and in the post-war
reconstruction, they would kind of,
occasionally impose a special levy
of whatever percent on the rich
people for five years or whatever.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's interesting you mention
wartime periods, because, you know, we've... So the
channel has really been growing and it's becoming
really popular, and you know, this... this argument of
why are you not taxing the rich is growing and growing
and growing and growing. And I think we actually
made some good progress, because for a long time we
would get this kind of economic pushbacks, it's not
good for the economy, it's not good for the economy.
There's no evidence for that.
No, there's not
and, but increasingly people are not believing that
but the argument against has kind of shifted
to this like, well, it's not possible
you can't tax rich people
and this kind of fatalistic,
well, things always get worse
you can't do anything.
But then if you look back at especially the
Second World War in Europe, in the West,
there was a massive decrease in wealth inequality.
Oh, absolutely.
So it's obviously, it's obviously doable.
Why... I don't know, have you got anything you
can say about whether it's possible, and also
why so many people are so quick to say it's
impossible when we have this historical example?
I think one reason why it is more
difficult than before is that downward
spiral that we have talked about, yeah?
Increasing inequality feeding into
increasing inequality of power
and democracy being more
and more constrained.
Yeah, yeah.
So, that's one reason why I think
it is more difficult to do that now than
Yeah.
it was possible in the 1950s or '60s.
I think this is a really good point because I
think people push back and they say it's impossible
because you can't do it technically, but the
Second World War proves it's technically possible.
The truth is, what makes it very, very difficult,
in my opinion, is that control of the media
and the control of politicians because
whenever I go on TV or radio
to campaign for wealth taxes,
I'm always doing it for free
and I'm self-funded.
And I'm up against somebody who works for a think tank
funded by billionaires.
And sometimes people... if you wonder why
there's not more voices like me in the media
because who funds it?
The billionaires are actively
paying for people to go on TV
go on the radio and say it's impossible to tax the rich.
Who is paying
for people like me to make the counterargument?
You know, basically nobody.
So that shows you
really, the way they block it
is by fighting that narrative battle.
And winning that narrative
Yeah, exactly, yeah, but there you have,
Nelson Mandela once said, "It always
looks impossible until it is done," yeah?
Yeah.
We can do it, we have to do it.
We have to start somewhere, yeah?
I mean,
okay, I mean change the narrative,
maybe put more pressure on your
politicians, yeah, and do more
mass economic literacy campaigns so that
more people know about these things like
you are doing in a very, very effective way.
I mean, we have to change this, yeah?
Yeah.
And it can be done.
Okay, maybe the 90% is too much, yeah?
But why should it be 40% or 50%?
It could be the 60%, 70%, yeah?
And I always talk about how it's not even
necessarily just about what rates we tax income.
You know, we have these very, very wealthy families-
That's right, we have-
they don't pay income tax.
tax wealth, yeah.
Yeah, I think this is the big thing.
They don't have income in the-
Yeah, their
income is not classed as income.
Exactly.
But, you know, they do receive billions
of pounds in their lifetime.
I think... I think often what is, what is often done
is when I say want to tax the rich, my opponents try
to convince the public that means you, that means you.
And they, they try to ignore, you know,
there are families out there with hundreds
of millions, billions of pounds of wealth.
Their wealth is growing and growing and growing
and they're squeezing people out.
Yeah.
They're squeezing people out.
This is the worry I have.
But, I think... I look at
the growth of this narrative
the massive growth and support for it.
I think we can win the public battle for it, but
I think we need more support from economists.
Which is why I'm always glad to hear
you're doing the work you're doing.
And I'm hoping we get more young people going
into economics to push this... push this narrative.
I think that, I think that's really good.
I guess I would like to end on just asking you,
I can often be a little bit pessimistic and a
little bit depressing, but I do this work
because I think we can make things better.
So at these times when living standards
are falling and we have increased political
turbulence, what is it that gives you hope for our
future as a society and our future as an economy?
Yeah, well, I, yeah, you know, try to live
by the dictum of the Italian Marxist
philosopher Antonio Gramsci who said
that we need the pessimism of the intellect,
but optimism of the will, yeah?
Yeah, so you have to be realistic about
what can be achieved at the moment.
Yeah.
You know, so that makes you pessimistic because
debts kind of stack so much against
the ordinary people, but in the long run, you
know, the world has changed hugely, yeah?
If changes weren't impossible
you know, we'd be still living in a
society with slaves and most people are
you know, tied to their land and do not have
any freedom to choose their profession.
You know, the women will not
be allowed to vote, you know.
There'll be explicit
racial discrimination.
But these things all have changed
because people have fought for it, yeah?
So if you take the perspective
of 50 years, 100 years, yeah?
We can change this, you know.
I think that's the key thing is
because people fought for it.
Yeah.
Because people fought for it.
Exactly.
I think we can.
I'm fighting for it.
I know you're doing your bit.
Yeah, thank you very much.
Thanks for coming on the channel.
That's great for me.
Is there anything you wanted to, you wanted to
bring up or anything you want to speak about?
I mean, I'm very honored to be the first
outside speaker in your great series.
Yeah, I mean, please get other
speakers so that you can diversify
your... I mean, what you are doing
is great, but, you know, we need
kind of different people coming in too.
Yeah, I think we need-
Give, different perspectives.
it's important for us to have more economists, I think.
Because this channel is like, it's getting so
popular with the public, but, you know, we have
all of these rich posh guys, "Oh, no, I never work.
Oh, no, I never work." And, you know, we live in a
very class-focused society. And, I think... I'm
from a working-class background, and think one of
the reasons why the channel is popular is because
the country's from a working-class background.
They're happy to hear that.
But the fact is, the guys who
control the levers of power
they're normally not from working-class backgrounds.
Yeah, but there are some kind of
good economists working on these issues.
You know, get Piketty or Zucman, yeah?
Yeah, you know, I think we'll reach out.
We'll reach out.
I think Piketty and Zucman are great.
They're French economists working in inequality.
But yeah, thank you very much for coming on.
Ha-Joon has not asked me to, to recommend his books,
but, I think Ha-Joon has a lot of books out.
His recent one is Edible Economics,
which is here on the table.
He didn't ask me to do this, honestly he didn't.
I think Ha-Joon writes really well economics in a
way that is enjoyable and relatable to ordinary people.
So, if you're watching and you find economics
inaccessible, and you want... I obviously
haven't written any books about economics,
like straight books about economics, but
I think Ha-Joon's books are really good.
And if you've got questions for Ha-Joon, send
them in and maybe we'll get him on again someday.
But, yeah, basically, thank you very much-
Thank you.
for coming on.
I really enjoyed this time.
Great.
And, yeah, good to see you again.
Thank you very much.
And thank you very much for your support.
Keep watching, share the videos
with your friends, with your mum.
It's all about stopping the economy from getting worse.
It's about taxing wealth and not work.
Support us.
Thank you very much.